I'd like to try to figure out together
with you sort of um
a way out
to try to decrease the amount of hate in
the world but maybe it's useful to talk
about the BBC documentary that
um it's kind of interesting that people
should check out it's called United
States of hate Muslims under attack and
you um you appear in that you have
conversations with people who are
anti-muslim and it's I believe most of
it takes place here in Dallas yeah and
can you just tell me about this uh
little documentary about that time what
it was like to interact what was the
group in the documentary and what was
like to interact with them you know in
the very beginning of um the rise
of at that time actually Ted Cruz Donald
Trump like when when islamophobia
uh was at the center of many of the
presidential candidates campaigns at the
time so this must have been 2015 yes
2015.
um the mayor of Irving at the time Beth
Van Dyne who is now a congresswoman
um had put out the idea
that Muslims were operating at Sharia
Court in Irving Texas
and suddenly there was hysteria because
again there's the idea that Muslims are
here to dominate Muslims are here to
overthrow everything that you have
um in the United States there was a
hysteria here
and it was unfortunate because
um what it Unleashed
you know especially with the national
discourse at the time again the
presidential campaign you know Donald
Trump says I think Islam hates us
when he uses those words I think Islam
hates us
when Ted Cruz suggests that Muslim
neighborhoods could be patrolled or
should be patrolled
and then you have the Irving mayor
saying that one of the most populated
cities with Muslims in America they're
operating under an alternative uh legal
and Alternate legal system and
funny enough the year before that she'd
come to the mosque and she praised the
diversity of Irving and she was talking
about how welcome she felt in the mosque
and the next thing we know you have
these crazy white supremacist groups
openly white supremacists that affiliate
themselves with
the clan and others
protesting regularly in front of our
mosques with their AR-15s and telling
people to go back home and I'm like I'm
from New Orleans I'm not planning to
move back to New Orleans I'm home we're
we're home we're good you know we're
staying put
and we refuse to be intimidated
um but then when the Syrian refugee
crisis is unfolding as well
Dallas has been one of the more popular
destinations if you will I'm not talking
about it like a vacation destination but
where a lot of refugees have come to
just because of the infrastructure that
we have set up here uh to receive
refugees
and so that hysteria uh was an
unfortunate perfect combustion of the
national discourse with the local
discourse with the incoming refugees
and we would do all sorts of Welcome
Refugee events and we do that you know
and and we don't only do that for Muslim
refugees by the way there are refugees
from other parts of the world as well
but we would host events at our mosques
you know to welcome refugees to help
integrate them into the community to do
things for them so you have these armed
protests happening right and it's
horrible because
think about the trauma to the children
that are hearing about tree of life and
hearing about some of these other
incidents that are unfolding and really
one of the first communities I was
targeted was the Sikh community in
Madison that was one of the first
shootings and then the AME Church
Charleston
and then you just had tons of places of
worship being targeted right so they're
seeing this unfold and they're seeing
these guns in front of their mosques and
the result
to money as well I just don't want to
get shot I don't want to go to the
mosque I don't want to have this happen
to me
so you know when BBC reached out and
said we want to do a documentary about
this uh unfortunately Dallas was the
only place in America where you had
regular armed groups in front of our
mosques it was happening around the
country infrequently but here it was
happening every week so the BBC reached
out and said we want to interview you I
said we've got this idea we want to put
you we want to take you to a park and
have you meet one of the protesters
uh who's been wielding his gun outside
your mosque and talked to him
and it was really interesting because
they'd interviewed him before meeting me
and the things that he was able to utter
before meeting me and before meeting
Syrian refugees
uh was just awful I mean the most
dehumanizing rhetoric that you can
imagine
but then at the park he meets me talks
to me he meets a Syrian refugee family
one of the girls whose leg had been
blown off in an airstrike
and he said I feel like an idiot I mean
he expressed all sorts of regret
and wisteriaite that he could dehumanize
people the way that he was and so my
whole thing was and is come inside the
mosque put your gun down
disarm yourself and learn
and you'll be surprised what you'll walk
away with
and only took one meeting with him
um
it's a completely
shift
his worldview at the time
which
was made up of heroes and villains the
Muslims unfortunately being the villains
that had to be wiped off the face of the
Earth so that the Earth could continue
so that was uh that was an interesting
documentary and it was an interesting
social experiment
uh what's it feel like to have
all these people that hate you
and others in the community people you
love
uh with guns
threatening violence
basically that we don't want you here in
this country on this Earth
um
it's not nice
it's not great I mean it's um
it's definitely a challenge but look
there are challenges that we face as as
Muslims
being in the United States being in a
hostile climate there are different
types of challenges and uh I think what
we've had to do as a Muslim Community
is see beyond both the guns and the
roses and think about who we are first
because frankly
uh
islamophobia exists in different forms
and from different sides
and we try to use this as an opportunity
to instill in our young people
not just the sense of belonging but a
sense of purpose
uh
do not be intimidated
and in fact show them the best of
Jerusalem live your life because at the
end of the day
the goal that is sought through
intimidation is silence
and so we have to carry ourselves as
proud American Muslims we don't have to
impress anyone
and we don't need to relinquish an iota
of our faith
to coexist with anyone we are satisfied
with who we are we don't we don't see a
contradiction
uh between
our place of residence and our religion
our nationality our religion we don't
see that as a problem right so that's a
that's something for them to work out
not for you to work out that's what I
would tell young Muslims that continue
to live your faith fully
and demonstrate the beauty of it and do
not let the ugliness of the world
consume you
but for those young Muslims what would
you say how they should feel towards the
people that hate them
the natural human
there's a desire still to have anger to
have
resentment to have hate back at the
people that hate you
the Quran says respond to that which is
evil with that which is better and you
will find that
sometimes your enemy will become your
close friends
so respond with that which is better
doesn't mean be passive sometimes there
needs to be a demonstration of strength
sometimes there needs to be a
demonstration of uh
ignoring a people altogether
But ultimately you can't let the way
people treat you shape who you're going
to be in the world
and so that's why I say we have to look
beyond the guns on the Roses we have to
look Beyond
the hostility of our enemies and the
temporary and opportunistic embrace of
some of those who claim to be our allies
and be us and treat the world and treat
the people of this world in accordance
with your standards
not with theirs so don't teach them
you know or don't let them teach you bad
character you teach them good character
so live your life and and live your
faith beautifully
and let people see the beauty of it
through your through your being and do
not let their ugliness
consume you but at the same time
sometimes you got to give people room to
express frustration to to say that this
is unacceptable to have demonstrations
of strength
and I think that those things don't have
to all contradict each other
what do you think about these kinds of
protests are not allowed in many parts
of the world what do you think about
one of the most do you directly
personally painful manifestations of the
first amendment of The People's right to
freedom of speech into protest to say
hateful things
uh you've been at the receiving end
of the worst of it
what what what do you feel about this
particular Freedom that uh that's at the
core of the founding of this country
look I think that you have to take it
away from the text and look at it within
reality let's be real uh would Muslims
be able to protest in front of churches
with guns on a weekly basis in this
country I don't think so so that the
pragmatically speaking there's a
hypocrisy too what's major hypocrisy
major hypocrisy see free speech
is an ideal that is weaponized against
the Muslim Community and against other
communities
and such a hypocritical way you know you
take for example some countries in
Europe you know let's kind of move away
from this and look at the hypocrisy of
uh a place like France where the
caricaturing and the portrayal of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him in
derogatory ways will be used as the
Hallmark of free speech
but
Muslims that will caricature uh macron
or challenge some of the values of
France the supposed and trying values of
France will end up in prison and end up
deported and so here in the United
States there's a great hypocrisy I don't
think that uh places of worship should
have armed protesters in front of them I
think that that poses a security risk I
think that it's not okay
um
and I think that free speech is
weaponized against the Muslim Community
and often is held up as this great value
but really to attain very lowly things
and uh is often to our detriments
yeah just even watching that documentary
it's hard to put into words but somehow
that
does not capture
what maybe the founders intended
right what uh what I would see is the
great ideal of the freedom of speech
um
I don't know what the solution to that
is
I think taking it outside of wards maybe
that requires a community a cultural
pressure to be better
uh
so it's not about the law it's more
about just the cultural pressure what
isn't isn't okay because there's
something deeply wrong about that kind
of hate
uh yeah because it was dehumanizing
other people there here in America
that there are Americans
yeah I mean it's it's we have to
interrogate
the foundations of our country when our
country is in such turmoil and such
chaos uh no country in the world has the
mass shootings that we have
no country in the world has
some of the polarization that we have we
have to interrogate that and say what it
is that we're doing wrong that's leading
to that
and I think again that it's it's
reaching a point where it's
unsustainable
um if we don't do better
and try to solve
some of the Rifts right now that exist
in our society
then we're going to end up in you know
in a place where we might we may not be
able to climb out of this